election results overnight could send
Britain deeper into political crisis
ahead of a new brexit deadline voters
favorite populist and nationalist
parties that want a weaker European
Union Ian Lee is in London with the
impact for the next prime minister and
the us and good morning to you a good
morning what these European elections
show is that brexit battle lines are
being drawn parties can no longer tiptoe
around the issue Britain say it's time
to take a stance giving a warning for
the next prime minister to serve the
country I know but there seemed to be
little love from the country or her
party as the door shuts on Teresa Mays
tenure she isn't going quietly into the
night though first she'll host president
Trump for a high profile state visit
despite her lame duck status May will
want to ensure a visible bond with the
United States as Britain enters the
unknown Michel Santo is a foreign policy
consultant there is pretty much no
stronger ally that we have than the
British and they're very important trade
partner they have a very strong
prosperous economy those ties could
translate to new trade opportunities
while president Trump will try to
minimize any damage to the strong
American economy in a post brexit
Britain I hope it doesn't harm the
global it kind of immune especially of
course they don't want it to see it harm
our own economy so you know this there
is a little bit of potential for chaos
and I'm not trying to say that brexit
will necessarily lead to long-term
damage it's just very risky guiding
Britain through brexit will be the role
of the new prime minister despite the
difficulties ahead more than a dozen
people are gunning for this top job I
will be standing for the leadership of
my party and as the next prime minister
I'm running to be the next prime
minister we'll be putting my name
forward to be prime minister of this
country but one candidate stands out
above the rest Boris Johnson the face of
the brexit movement that some critics
say got this country here in the first
place and the bookies and odd makers
place Boris Johnson as being the
favorite but in recent Conservative
Party leadership contest the
front runner rarely wins meaning the
smart money is on the underdog Anthony
could be a couple of chaotic months
ahead in Britain thanks Ian